Guten Morgen und willkommen zu einem ganz speziellen Video!
Der Hamza schläft noch, es ist grad Sonntag in der Früh. Ich versuche, das Ganze in Eigenregie aufzunehmen!
Und zwar wollte ich euch heute gerne zeigen, wie so ein typisch türkisches Frühstück aussehen kann und da nehme ich euch jetzt einfach mal mit!
So kleine Schälchen sind natürlich immer Gold wert beim türkischen Frühstück.
Also ihr braucht ganz viele kleine Schälchen.
Und ich beginne jetzt mit Tahin Pekmez.
Das ist eigentlich nur ein Mix aus Sesampaste und Traubenmelasse und das ist so typisch türkisch!
Das dippt man dann später zusammen mit Brot.
Da gebe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen Sesam rein.
Und fertig!
So, Variante 2 ist: Ihr nehmt euch Sesampaste wieder, da gebt ihr diesmal Honig rein
und ein bisschen Kakao. Ich nehme hier tatsächlich heute mal Trinkkakao weil der sich einfach besser verbindet.
Perfekt!
Schmeckt jetzt wie Helva, also Helva kennen die meisten von euch.
Ist eigentlich eine feste Konsistenz aber das schmeckt wie verflüssigte Helva, also auch sehr lecker!
Etwas, das noch typisch türkisch ist, ist Bal Kaymak. Das ist eigentlich nur Kaymak mit Honig.
Und Kaymak ist ein Milcherzeugnis, besteht nur aus Kuhmilch und ist so die türkische Mascarpone!
So, und jetzt nehmen wir uns ganz einfach Kaymak, geben das in die Schale..
und da kommt einfach Honig drüber.
So, fertig!
So und jetzt noch ein paar Dips, die habe ich ehrlicherweise vom Türken.
Und die gehen einfach immer. Also alles, was ihr dippen könnt, ist richtig!
Da gibt's kein richtig oder falsch!
Frischkäse Dip, Knoblauch Dip...geht alles!
So!
In die nächsten 2 Schälchen gebe ich Oliven, ganz, ganz wichtig beim türkischen Frühstück!
Und zwar schwarze und grüne.
So, perfekt!
So, nachdem ich die kleinen Schälchen vorbereitet habe, kommt jetzt eine Käse- und Wurstplatte.
Jeder, wie er mag! Wir essen mehr Käse als Wurst, daher schaue ich mal, wie ich das Ganze verteile.
Und dann darf natürlich auch Gemüse nicht fehlen!
Das heißt im Anschluss werde ich auch noch Gemüse schneiden und ganz zum Schluss kommt dann Menemen.
Menemen ist eine typisch türkisch Eierspeise.
Ganz, ganz traditionell mit frischen Tomaten angebraten quasi. Zeige ich euch gleich auch noch!
So, ich nehme am liebsten eine große, runde Schieferplatte.
Dann fange ich an, einfach Wurst und Käse und ein bisschen Grünzeug darauf zu verteilen.
So, die Käse- und Wurstplatte, da halte ich es ganz einfach.
Da gebe ich verschiedene Käsesorten, ein bisschen Wurst dazu.. Auf jeden Fall Grünzeug, ganz, ganz wichtig!
Was mir jetzt hier fehlt ist Schafskäse, das ist auch super wichtig!
Das habe ich tatsächlich vergessen, einzukaufen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier noch Geflügelwurst und schneide das hier mit dem Wellenschneider zurecht.
Und das gleiche mache ich gleich mit dem Wellenschneider auch noch mit Gemüse, das ich hier auch noch mit dazu gebe.
So, Tomaten dürfen nicht fehlen!
So, das ist jetzt noch Suçuk, türkische Knoblauchwurst.
Ganz, ganz typisch! Ich glaube, es gibt kein Frühstück ohne die türkische Knobiwurst!
Die gebe ich jetzt gleich noch für ein paar Sekunden ohne Fett in die Pfanne.
Das mache ich aber wirklich erst kurz bevor wir anfangen, zu frühstücken weil die schmecken auch wirklich nur wenn sie dann noch warm sind!
Hier seht ihr gerade, wie ich noch Menemen zubereite. Das ist eine typisch türkische Eierspeise, also ganz traditionell!
Da wird erstmal grüne Peperoni in etwas Butter angedünstet.
Dann geben wir frische Tomaten dazu, - da habe ich die Haut vorab entfernt -
zerdrücken das schön mit der Gabel oder mit einem anderen Utensil.
Ich gebe da dann Salz und andere Gewürze mit dazu.
Ihr könnt z.B. Pul Biber nehmen, das ist scharfes Paprikapulver.
Bei mir darf Oregano z.B. auch nie fehlen aber da seid ihr komplett frei.
Und dann lasst ihr das richtig schön lange köcheln bevor ihr die Eier dazugebt.
Wenn ich jemanden einlade, darf bei mir nie Börek fehlen und ich liebe die panierten Sigara Böreks!
Das Video verlinke ich euch dazu am besten mal in der Infobox, das könnt ihr super auch schon am Vorabend zubereiten.
Und das ist halt alles andere als fettig weil wir das im Backofen zubereiten.
Falls euch das Video gefallen hat, dann würde ich mich riesig freuen, wenn ihr mir Kommentare da lasst!
Und falls ihr eine arabische Variante sehen möchtet, dann gebt mir doch gerne bescheid
denn wenn die Schwiegermutter demnächst zu Besuch kommt, dann gibt's ein leckeres arabisches Frühstück und das kann ich dann auch gerne für euch mitfilmen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss, eure Kiki!